on sait pas toi en haut moi en bas
et c'est parti
je vois qu'on est joueur
ça c'est nouveau
[Musique]
bataille de boules de neige
c'est trop facile allez monte le
dimanche
[Musique]
ça c'est ce qui s'appelle avoir du style
appelez-moi Mister cool
génial le soldat de l'hiver
pour quelqu'un qui dit avoir de la
poigne t'as pas beaucoup de patates
renonce tu ne peux rien contre moi je me
suis entraîné à me battre ma vie entière
comme quoi ça sert pas à grand chose
parce que moi j'ai eu aucun entraînement
et je suis toujours devant pas trop
dégoûté
de ta part tu es incapable tu es
incompétent
tu es
intigne
a oublié une chose je suis imbattable
[Musique]
c'est mon destin de réussir ou mes
ancêtres ont échoué et de remettre enfin
le pouvoir absolu entre les mains de mon
peuple
le pouvoir absolu mais j'ai aucune idée
de ce que tu racontes je dois te tromper
de Hérisson ah le pouvoir absolu
voilà que tu parles mon langage ne joue
pas avec moi apprenti de l'enclos
l'enclos et son peuple était les pires
ennemis de ma tribu c'est le déséquinée
nous avons lutté et nous sommes tombés
sous leur cou à ton tour de mourir sous
les miens
je suis de ton côté pardon mais tu es
qui toi
aucune importance
salut
[Musique]
Ie super franchement c'est un honneur de
te rencontrer enfin Sonic je peux
t'appeler Sonic au fait moi c'était ça
veut dire que tu te demandes peut-être
pourquoi je réfléchis parce que tu as de
queue exact je savais que tu
comprendrais cool mais sinon c'est quoi
ce délire robotique revient et qui sait
l'autre là Clifford le gros monstre
rouge
c'est le dernier des techniques le
guerrier le plus dangereux de la galaxie
son obsession c'est trouver l'émeraude
mère tu es sérieux l'émeraude mer c'est
que des histoires pour les enfants ça
doit penser que c'est grâce à toi qui va
la trouver
[Musique]
pour la semaine je crois
on n'a pas du tout sommet
j'ai une idée ta confiance en moi bien
sûr que non je t'ai rencontré il y a 5
minutes laisse-moi qu'est-ce que tu fais
[Musique]
on vole
attends je rêve tu es devenu un fessier
cocktail
ma destiné et de protéger mes amis et ma
famille je crois que je vais me vomir
dessus et si tu veux cette émeraude tu
vas devoir te battre contre moi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'équipe né ne fait pas de
quartier
Sonic un cœur mais après si t-il
vraiment le piquant de la vie
je voulais pas en arriver là mais tu me
laisses pas beaucoup le choix
trop facile finissons-en
pour mourir avec honneur je vais y
réfléchir ok j'ai réfléchi merci mais
non merci
salut ma précieuse
alors toi tu fais pas semblant
[Musique]
au revoir
hérisson
fera diversion
un instant ce n'est pas ce qui était
convenu
oh
pauvre créature candide pour rien un
esprit plus évolué aurait vu le couvenir
à un kilomètre au moins ou 0,6 miles je
te faisais confiance nous sommes comme
frère
[Rires]
que ce soit ma première et dernière
leçon petit furoncle céleste un ami
c'est empathique honnête et ouvert aux
besoins de l'autre ce qui veut dire que
X au carré fois l'hypoténuse de y² / la
valeur absolue de la mi égale